fifty-four years after Disney brought
Mary Poppins to life on the big screen
the magical British nanny is back
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm John and
in this video and comparing Mary Poppins
returns to the 1964 classic revealing
the biggest differences and whether it's
a worthy sequel when Julie Andrews made
her film debut as Mary Poppins over half
a century ago she lit up the screen with
her take on author P L Travers
no-nonsense nanny I'm sure it must be
daunting for any actor to step into
Andrews practically perfect shoes but if
anyone's the right person to slip on
Mary Poppins very particular footwork
then it's Emily Blunt who's repeatedly
showing what an incredibly versatile and
meticulous actress she is this latest
version of Mary Poppins isn't exactly
the same as the original movie and it's
certainly not an impersonation of Judy
Andrews either blunt took her Poppins
cues from the character P L Travers
created in her books which means she's
somewhat sterner sharper and ruder than
in the first film and then does Mary's
new accent which I wasn't sure about
when I heard it in the trailer Burt
pish-posh - that quite frankly as when I
saw the film I've got to say the accent
wasn't an issue for me yes Blunt has
gone many times Pacha than her own
received pronunciation or Julie Andrews
for that matter but her performance sold
her clipped heightened tones inspired by
British royalty and made it work in the
1930s context of the film as for the
song and dance numbers Blunt looks like
she's having a total blast which makes
watching her a real joy so while she
takes her Mary in a different direction
to Andrews each actress is beguiling in
the role in her own way and just seeing
Mary Poppins come floating down through
the skies once more may well bring a
tear to your eye
in the original Mary Poppins Dick Van
Dyke was such an absolute ball of energy
as the all-singing all-dancing chimney
sweep street artists and one-man-band
Bert that he practically burst off the
screen though a new addition to the
story lin-manuel Miranda's character
Jack the Lamplighter is given a brief
backstory woven in with the original
characters as it turns out that he used
to be Bert's apprentice Van Dyke's
larger-than-life performances Bert is so
memorable that it's a really tough act
to follow but Miranda is an accomplished
musical performer and plays Jack with a
good deal of charm
in fact Jack not only inherits Bert's
childlike wonder and optimism was also
his interesting take on a cockney accent
as I live and breathe
Miranda's attempt is a touch better than
Van Dyke's though he's helped by the
fact that unlike the 1964 film the
sequel opens with Jack singing rather
than speaking so the faulty accent
doesn't quite hit you as immediately
comical poi shoot it before the occasion
except right before your very eyes
speaking of Dick Van Dyke he makes a
very welcome return in the sequel this
time we're told that jack-of-all-trades
Bert is off travelling in parts unknown
so instead Van Dyck makes a cameo as mr.
doors junior who also appeared in the
first film they played by a different
actor in fact mr. doors junior is the
son of former bank chairman mr. door
senior who was the second character Van
Dyck played in the original film and let
me tell you it really is amazing to see
the 90 something year old actor singing
and dancing with incredible gusto once
more and amazingly he looks pretty much
just like he did when he appeared as mr.
door senior and full old man makeup back
in the 1960s with the sequel taking
place around 25 years after the original
movie the banks children Michael and
Jane and now the adults of the story
these days Jane follows the activist
path of her mother and Michael works for
fidelity fiduciary bank just like his
father did before him also much like his
dad Michael's problems and preoccupation
with work means he's lost his childlike
joy and both films are about getting
that back and appreciating your family
while Michael does lose his temper with
his children similar to his father
overall he's less Stern and markedly
gentler with his kids and also much less
prim and proper than his dad Ben Whishaw
brings a lovely delicate touch to the
role of the grieving Michael and his
performance of The Melancholy song a
conversation proves a real tearjerker
and Emily Mortimer is delightful as Jane
mixing can-do spirit with moments of shy
sweetness so many of the songs composed
by the Sherman Brothers for the 1964
movie became well-loved classics still
remembered fondly by children and adults
today whether it's the oscar-winning gym
humor
a spoonful of sugar
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious jolly
holiday let's go fly a kite or feed the
birds if you're watching this video then
you'd likely know at least the tune if
not a good number or even all the lyrics
as those songs obviously following the
Sherman Brothers is a tall order then
still Marc Shaiman and Scott Wittman who
composed the musical Hairspray have done
a top-notch job capturing the tone of
the original movie and recreating the
kind of tunes that reflects the style
and era it's tough to say if the songs
were as iconic as the originals given
how many times we've heard those in
comparison but many of them are
definitely very catchy and others
certainly grow on you
my favorite song among the new batch is
a cover is not the book which is a
dazzling humorously innuendo laid and
vaudeville number brought two rollicking
life with spirited performances by Emily
Blunt and lin-manuel Miranda as well as
the fast paced burn of trifa little
light fantastic can you imagine that and
the Royal Doulton Music Hall we also get
the delightfully lilting underneath the
lovely London sky and the heartfelt
lullaby the place where lost things go
and although the new cast don't perform
any of the songs from the original movie
you will hear traces of their melodies
carefully woven into the score at
several suitable points throughout the
film Mary Poppins returns is a real love
letter to the 1964 movie made with
obvious affection by all involved in
fact it reminds me in some ways of Star
Wars The Force awakens which likewise
reek extorted a popular property after a
long absence but is it as original as a
classic movie well no in many ways it
can't be because it takes us back to a
place we already know and reminds us of
that throughout with numerous echos of
the original film and story beats
characters visuals and songs but
director Rob Marshall and screenwriter
David McGee's nostalgia filled film does
manage to put enough of its own twist on
things and finds added inspiration in P
L Travers various Mary Poppins books of
course there are so many wonderful
moments of magic in the 1960s movie from
Marion the children tidying the nursery
to uncle Albert's herbal and tea party
to the step in time rooftop dance
sequence and of course who can forget
the artful mix of live-action anime
we're Mary Burton the children jump
inside a chalk drawing of the typical
English countryside mary poppins returns
also has some appealing magic scenes
including the children's bath time which
turns into an underwater fantasy and the
sequels take on the step in time scene
is a fun reverse of the original where
the children go down in the world via
London lampposts rather than up on the
rooftops best of all though is the
gorgeous Royal Doulton China Bowl
sequence which features a raucous music
hall and mixes live action and
hand-drawn animation and I also really
love the genius touch of having the
character's clothes appear hand-painted
in fact oscar-winning costume designer
sandy powers work throughout this movie
is simply stunning
while the sequel does gift us special
appearances from Dick Van Dyke and Karen
dotrice who played Jane Banks in 1964
sadly the original Mary Poppins Julie
Andrews doesn't appear because according
to the movie's director she didn't want
to distract from the sequel being
Emily's show however we do get a
charming cameo from another screen
legend Angela Lansbury who makes an
appearance as the balloon lady a
character from P L Travers books
Lansbury even gets to sing a song in her
inimitable style and her presence in the
film feels practically perfect
especially given her musical history
with Disney starring in their live
action film Bedknobs and Broomsticks and
the animated Beauty and the Beast where
she voiced mrs. Potts and memorably sang
the title song another addition to the
sequel is Meryl Streep's character Topsy
who like Lansbury's balloon lady is
adapted from P L Travers books
this is Streep third film with Emily
Blunt following The Devil Wears Prada
and into the woods and she's clearly
having a ball totally hamming it up with
a deliberately OTT accent as Mary's
eccentric cousin Streep's appearance in
the movie includes a deliciously jazzy
showstopper called turning turtle and
the whole scene feels like a fun
callback with a twist to the first
film's laugh filled floating scene with
Uncle Albert by the way I've got a video
about all the sequels Easter eggs which
are linked to here and in the video
description
at times Mary Poppins returns it's a
little more melancholy than the original
after all Michael has lost his wife and
the children their mother and they're
about to be evicted from their home
in that respect it's similar to another
recent musical sequel mama mia here we
go again which coincidentally also
starred three of this film's cast
nevertheless there's still plenty of
uplifting cheery fun as well as hope and
happiness to be had with emily Blunt's
mary sure bringing the magical British
nanny back on screen after over 50 years
absence is no easy task
this generation after generation has
grown up with Julie Andrews classic
performance and watching that movie
feels like getting a big old hug burst
if you let yourself experience a sequel
with a kind of childlike wonder that
Mary Poppins advocates then you'll
likely enjoy its genuine warmth than the
delightfully old-fashioned appeal it
certainly put a big smile on my face and
I'll happily watch it again and listen
to the soundtrack as well now how do you
think Mary Poppins returns compares to
the first film and what are your
favorite moments or songs in the new
movie let me know in the comments below
tapleft to watch my Mary Poppins Returns
Easter eggs video or tap write for
another Mary Poppins video you're sure
to like congratulations to the winner of
my Ralph breaks the internet giveaway
make sure you contact me so I can send
you the prize if you enjoyed this I
really appreciate a thumbs up and a
share thanks for watching and see you
next time
yippie Kay we'll be lovers